we have this from the New York Post U.S
Marshals told not to arrest abortion
protesters at scotus justices homes U.S
Marshals assigned to protect Supreme
Court Justices Holmes following the
reversal of Roe v Wade last year were
directed not to arrest protesters unless
absolutely necessary according to newly
revealed documents Senator Katie Britt
unveiled a series of training slides
used to prepare Marshals for their
assignments as she grilled attorney
general Merrick Garland at a senate
appropriation subcommittee hearing
Tuesday the slides instructed the
marshals to avoid unless absolutely
necessary any criminal enforcement
involving protesters and that making
arrests and initiating prosecutions was
not the goal of their being stationed
outside the residence of the Court's six
conservative jurists so I think
the plane is there you can see it right
there someone showed up trying to kill
Kavanaugh and his family they said
outright no no no no enforcement let him
go let them do their thing it's illegal
by the way and the reason it's illegal
is that I believe it was in the 50s they
said judges are not elected officials or
these at least in the same way and if
judges cannot be free from political
pressures there is no justice because
that's how the court system works so
they said in this instance no protesting
judges
these people are now doing it the left
is defending it someone tried to kill
this man and Merrick Garland is saying
you're free to keep breaking the law
where's where's where's the but then he
did the Republicans right yeah exactly
and that was the problem is that it took
this long too to figure it out why why I
mean you know it would have been nice if
you're a Kavanaugh or his family to know
this like a few months ago when it was
happening but the idea that that Merrick
Garland stood there today and kind of
denied that he had any insight into this
happening there are training materials
Katie Brett the senator from Alabama is
literally posting up these slides saying
here's what the shows and he's like I
have no idea that's a bad sign for him
like why would you say I have no idea
what these people who are but they're
directly in my chain of commanders
there's a level there's a point at which
you're either incompetent or lying but
it's one of the two
which one is it I mean you either don't
know what's happening in your department
because because think about this isn't
like hey did you know about the guard at
the front gate right uh you know I
didn't know okay well there's 18 doors
and there's a bunch of buildings these
are Supreme Court Justices that are
being threatened and you're the guy
that's saying I'm going to send U.S
Marshals to augment the security at some
point wouldn't you know about the what
they call the Rules of Engagement like
hey what are you telling these guys yeah
and what information was given to the
justices can you imagine being Brett
Kavanaugh and saying you know shouldn't
I be able to move my family out of the
area I mean if you don't think
protesters are going to
be I mean what's the point you're just
going to station there so the protesters
can be outside terrify the family
potentially get more raucous it could
get more dangerous and you're going to
say that well we're going to avoid
arresting them for as long as possible
like you're not really protecting them
it's because you're really dealing with
their children Merrick Garland was
supposed to be on the Supreme Court at
least that's what he's probably thinking
so he's probably smiling and laughing as
well he's also pissed about the decision
well of course right he's like you know
what you want to vote against Roe you
know what I'm not having your I don't
have your back well he's thinking it
should have been me yeah it should have
been me and I wouldn't have this
wouldn't have happened yep yep he's
probably sitting there so he's laughing
they deserve this yeah like that's
craziness I mean come on these people
are clearly insane you know so he's the
I imagine he's sitting there laughing
about this being like you shouldn't have
been there in the first place it's your
own fault this is so horrible I have
something I want to say that I'm not
comfortable saying on YouTube it's so
dark this is so ridiculous I'm going to
write it down and talk about on the
after show
here's the other thing that I would just
say that is interesting because
this this has started to you know
whether or not it's it's a Supreme Court
Justice
it's a government official it's a member
of Congress you talked about that
there's a point at which people start to
say I'm not running for office I'm not
serving I'm not speaking out I'm not
whatever it is there's a level of which
this is not worth it anymore and and you
talk Matt Walsh speaking out Brett
Kavanaugh serving in as a supreme court
and you know so and so running for
office so-and-so serving in the in the
government at some point you say this
isn't I'm gonna shut up whether serious
or not there have been people who have
been like Tim you should run you should
run and my response is I could not
imagine having all of the problems of
Fame and none of the money it's like if
you want to be in office in politics I
think you're nuts because Kavanaugh
makes what like 270 000 a year and he's
got people outside his home threatening
his family's life one guy tried to kill
him and his family and I'm like man so
you must really want that job and really
believe in it to to live that way I mean
not just that look at the lies they
spread about people like Matt Gates do
dude's not making a whole lot of money
doing this I'm surprised there are
people who want Donald Trump lost money
his his taxes only showed that as
president he was losing money and still
giving away his salary it's amazing they
were like once we get his tax return
we're going to prove oh he was losing
money haha he lost money it's like so
you're saying he made a huge personal
sacrifice to be president come on spare
me at the very beginning of the story I
missed a part of what you were saying
about what mayor Garland says he didn't
know which was These Guys these six guys
uh orders is that what it was no they so
the there's these slides come out today
Katie Brett the center from Alabama
while he's at the subcommittee basically
puts up a series of trading slides that
they were given to the U.S Marshals
right and the training slides
are basically saying don't don't arrest
these protesters as they engage with
these Supreme Court Justices as they I
mean Tim's pointing out like it's
illegal what the if you go protest at
their houses okay and there should be
arrested and the training sides are like
hey hands off guys don't don't do it
just let them be on their way right
telling cops not to enforce the law and
then Merrick says and the cop said you
got it buddy don't worry these cops I
gotta tell you man this is where you get
me right up to the to the defund the
police abolish the police and we've
talked about it before these are the
people who will pull you over for the
for a Myron fraction and say tell it to
a judge and give you no leeway these are
people that shut down businesses during
covid and and arrested men and women for
simply trying to sell coffee and then
when they're witnessing something
overtly illegal on the books they are
told by superiors
but but I will say this I haven't talked
to a lot of buddies of mine in law
enforcement they this is the stuff that
irks them that they're like my hand like
I want to do my job I cannot like the
the this they didn't get into law
enforcement to stand there they could
arrest them they if that's what they're
told they can't they can uh well I mean
then they get then they immediately in
New York City there are police officers
there's this funny story where this
morbidly obese older woman walks around
with no shirt on and in New York it's
legal for women to be topless because of
uh equality ruling in the courts and
there are cops who know she's allowed to
do it they don't care they arrest her
anyway they say man put a shirt on she
goes no no we're arresting you because
in their mind and then she Sues and she
wins every time she's done a bunch of
times it's a ridiculous story
the problem is these cops are cowards
they're absolute cowards and nothing
will convince me otherwise there isn't
these are these are the kind of cops
that are like they they instructed me to
shoot the dog or they told me I had to
arrest the old lady I have no choice but
to violate the rights of people because
someone else told me to do it I look
forward to if if it ever comes down to
hearings on covet lockdown and and and
the violations of law we're having these
cops come in and firing them and
stripping them of their pensions and
saying now you can live in a cardboard
box because you thought it was prudent
to ignore your oath to uphold the law
because your political boss told you not
to enforce it I won't play those games
and we need a politician maybe it's not
gonna be a politician we need an elected
official who the first thing they do is
they call in the federal police officers
and they say which one of you did not
enforce the law all of you you're all
fired and I'm gonna say to it your
family never sees a penny and
they go oh but but I was told just not
to enforce the law and let far far left
extremists go in front of just judges
homes and and threaten their lives well
that's too bad for you These
Guys these cops need to be the first in
line to feel the punishment because as
long as these cops are allowed to keep
breaking the law ignoring the law or
enforcing fake laws the system is
completely broken when I see salon
owners get arrested under
unconstitutional edict when I see
churches shut down and police officers
enforcing the shutdown of churches in
violation of the Constitution with Cuomo
saying even though the Supreme Court of
New York ruled against me saying I'm not
allowed to do this I'll just create
another executive order and do it anyway
you know why because these
cops will absolutely enforce edict from
these Executives even if it's against
the law because no one will go to them
as individuals and say I will destroy
you for enforcing this people
keep making excuses for the cops who are
doing this and if it's not the cops it
doesn't have happen if there were no
police officers there would be no
unconstitutional lockdown if there were
no cops there would be no churches shut
down during covid and everyone gave them
a free pass when the cops went to that
gym attilis in New Jersey and arrested
the people people outside of it or I
think the owners got huge fines got shut
down everyone's like well I don't blame
the cops they're being told to do it no
no I blame them twice as much now
because the worst thing the cops the
cops could have done they can do they
can say if you're telling me to not
enforce the law I will not show up I
will not swear enough to uphold the law
in the Constitution and then have you
tell me to break that out but these are
oath Breakers these are pieces of human
trash I have no respect for them at all
and if it were up to me and if I was
ever in office and I would I would
request this right now and I know no
one's going to do it because our
politicians are all cowards I'm giving
no no respect and no benefit to any
Republican because none of them will do
it I want them to take a single officer
from that photograph get their name
plaster it in Congress and say I am
coming for you I am going to take from
you your pension and your retirement and
I want your family to know it's because
you refuse to uphold the law if you come
into this office if you put on that
badge and say outright it's someone
else's fault I won't do my job I will
make sure you lose everything because if
you don't want to do your job this job's
not for you you can resign right now no
one's going to do it no one's going to
do it conservatives are going to keep
looking the boots of these cops who who
bashed them over the head during coven
and who refuse to enforce the law to
protect our justices if the judges can't
issue rulings because they're under
threat of death there can be no justice
and these cops are going but it's not my
fault I was told not to enforce the law
okay then get out fire them rant over
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time